is this Kurdistan's moment are they
going to finally achieve independence
you know if you ask any Kurd that
they're gonna say that they want
independence but the problem really
comes down to the Kurdish leadership
Massoud Barzani the Leader of Iran
Kurdistan who's now serving the ninth
year of his eighth year of presidency
oftentimes tries to rally Kurds around
the flag of Kurdish nationalism but when
push comes to shove it seems he wants
money more than nationalism
remember back in 1996 he invited Saddam
Hussein's forces into the Kurdish
capital simply because he didn't want
another Kurdish rival to take power now
when it comes to the PKK this group in
Turkey that's waging an insurgency or
this group in Syria which is established
an autonomous region they're no longer
officially talking about separatism
they're talking about federalism they're
actually talking about what they call
democratic autonomy or confederalism
where they want a group of Kurdish
regions which overlay other countries so
what's your opinion of Kurdish
independence let us know in the comments
and also let us know whether their
topics you want us to cover here at AEI
in 60 seconds